we can never say businesses as business
because if you passionate about
everything is personal my only
competition is to be myself make sure
you got a lot of loyalty right not a
real people I want to see you be the
best person you can be
the motivation
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from teaching himself how to sing and
dance as a young child to becoming a
musician selling over 100 million albums
worldwide and being one of the
best-selling musicians of all time his
Chris Brown and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't chase money we can never say
business is his business because if you
passionate about everything is personal
right you tell me so with me when I do
songs with people I don't do it to be
like oh I'm know how to do right now I'm
not charging them for verses you know
like when I when I come into New York
and we do a press run
I'm calling you like yes what you need
I'm coming you know because that's what
it's all about is well love's not about
who we getting out of it I don't do
music cuz it make me rich you know
that's the plus you know I would have
been doing this if it was free you know
I'm saying yeah I get free music on all
the time rule number two have a great
work ethic you continue to amaze me with
the rate at which you put the music out
I think as far as singers songwriters I
would say you turn material around
probably one of the fastest right I mean
how much material are you making out of
Tom right now how many songs a day well
is is right now it's actually been
better cuz now just bit the studio in my
house so I've never had to leave you
know but uh for me I'm alone alone right
now I have like 800 songs but nobody's
hurt but not bragging is just my work
ethic only allows me to stay creative so
you know I won't I'll never try to make
my last hit like I gotta make this kind
of song and I think when it comes to
music now even in you know the execs
everybody they're they're numbers kind
of people there oh they're hot because
this is the trending thing mean that's
cool I like everybody else's but when it
comes down to actual working in the
studio I'll get on the record with
everybody a new person old person you
know I love the music in himself so me
being able to create it and adding a
bunion rate you know for me I think he's
just a blessing I'm just thankful and
appreciative I can do this 14 13 14
years later you know every day is I have
to work hard not for anybody else's Lane
if anybody else is a blessing much to
everybody but as far as me my only
competition is to be myself but not on
the lacerated myself just in life just
to see if I can always prove prove
myself wrong you know we doubt ourselves
a lot so proving myself wrong is my goal
rule number three
be driven one was 16 year old Chris
Brown's overall expectations for his
career as a singer over expectation is
as for me to be at the level I think I
want to say at the level of Mikey
Michael Jackson was yeah
or is it sir I wanna I wanna be so
they're like oh that's that's Chris
Brown let's kiss breath everybody like
everybody no Michael I don't care who
you are
everybody knows Michael Jackson why
would you say that you and that cutie
patootie and already we're gonna comment
stuff um the drive passion looking at
myself it kind of you know maybe like
man I was I was so hungry back then I
was so ready like you know but I still
feel that way you know it's just a
little bit more well I can articulate a
lot more I was like yeah I kind of
needed to go to a couple of media
training classes I didn't go to but it
was good but I think definitely you know
the drive I mean I mean that can still
have it
rule number four believe in yourself
your stage presence the art that you put
behind it and I've seen the rehearsals
and I see how serious this is for you is
is appreciated especially during times
like this when we see music be so
disposable you still care so much about
this Chris you don't have to anymore you
know that right like if you have to yeah
we all got a kid that's the difference
see the music that you you knew you said
that are perfect you start to smile I
see me I see but it starts like for me
at the end of the day I could have
jewelry on I could have anything that I
feel comfortable in whole way I think
the idea of dope is you know I'm saying
there's an aspiration there's a goal but
there's also limitations because we
doubt ourselves so what I'm sort of what
I'm getting that why that is the things
that I do in my artistry whether it be
direct or you know being hands-on giving
100% is because everybody's gonna say no
everybody's gonna give you that oh
you're not good enough but it's the only
one that makes you different than
anybody else and makes you succeed in
saying no that's I
agree with that because you're free so
whatever I do I leave by my own mistakes
and examples so the risks that I take
with music and the risk that I take with
certain songs or even just doing
whatever I want to do you know it's not
just because I want to reveal I can
reflect on in there but I can inspire
people to know that they can create
whatever they want they have that
capability rule number five think ahead
have you thought about the next
evolution of Chris Brown like what that
becomes as an artist have you even got
to that or you just focus on this out
right now that's a good question I think
for me I'm always ahead of schedule
thinking we do like even in fashion
certain things we always prepped for
like for one spring one different things
ahead of time so I think my strategy is
kind of like controlled chaos because
I'll record as many songs as possible or
just you know go off a vibe and then
I'll shoot it or come up with idea and
directly so I have the freedom you know
to curate I'll actually be dictating my
whole project with without anybody's
opinion except for my fans because I
want to know their feedback let's do it
rule number six engage with your
audience ever like favorite a tweet or I
like just nothing like that because
that's like my favorite thing whenever I
tweet like an artist or something that I
like admire and I see they see I'm like
yeah dude I'm like surprised your fans
are but I do it often actually um
sometimes if people showcase like some
people do covers to my songs or some
people you know show that a painting or
their room for the posters or whatever
and our favorite adorn our retweet I'm
just a given I love you know just to be
interactive and it's better to be
engaging with you know your audience and
your fans because you know at the end of
the day they support you there your rule
number seven surround yourself with
greatness the main thing I would say to
somebody if they ask me or some some new
artist it might ask me for advice
alright I don't take my advice because I
always show you the wrong way to do it
you know what the end of the day I tell
you know just tell them to keep that
circle really tight you know make sure
you got a lot of loyalty right a lot of
real people I want to see you be the
best person you can be not just for what
can bring them you know Fame
well whatever it is you know so I just
make sure people at the right team
around you got people who who are smart
who are thinking about your best
interest it's all rule number eight give
it a shot
do not conform and do anything just
because somebody else says it's wrong
it's right a lot of us based our fears
off of other people's insecurities other
people saying they're not good enough
you not get it but unless you try how
you know the only reason you aren't
achieving the goals you want to achieve
is because your mind hasn't said you can
do it again soon as you say you can
failure does not mean failure better to
me success because you learned from it
and you actually see that you gave you a
hundred percent rule number nine be fair
you know I started out fifteen and Tina
Davis showed me the game kind of so and
even from jump it wasn't a like even
with my production team in the beginning
when I first thought I had a lot of
greedy people and you know my deal
wasn't set up as as great as I would
like it to be so she came in and
actually changed the whole deal around
Tina and for me kind of showed me okay
this is what you deserved is what you
get and for me like I've done the
groundwork I've worked hard for
everything that I got and it's paid off
so it's not in my nature to take from
anybody else that has the same goals or
ambitions to be as great or fulfill
their destiny so I see the talent in
seven I see the talent in all my artists
and for me it's like yo man yes braids I
got my money is cool like when I do
deals like if it's a publishing deal
she got a large amount of money for that
but the way I structured the deal is if
if the the actual publisher whether it
be Universal whoever they go with they
they split whatever they make yeah with
me they don't I don't I don't take no
money off of what they make cuz I want I
want everybody that you know everybody
with me man we all eat like I don't I
can't I can't be the only one shining
hundred thousand dollar watch on and
then they over there like I got a
checkbook to become he stays buzz we
come see that's wrong
understand of business because you know
I feel like you know being yourself goes
further than trying to get over and then
you count your blessings down but you
know cutting other people's feet from
under and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun question fire will you help with the
disaster yeah yeah I'm just a man
the burnout was amazing I'm here with
Chris Brown and if you know me I'm just
like a mess hey but this I don't know
now I'm acting like a [ __ ] cuz she has
lights on her phone this is amazing
we're and this Christmas will be a very
special Christmas for me
[Music]
uh sugar hand shake hand y'all Rudolph
the red-nose gangbang there had a bunch
of hos and if you ever saw them you
could say that he has Bank rolls all of
the other stats
you still haven't call them names but
every time I go to the strip club I get
to see for free
and I don't have to pay
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Chris Brown on how to not be naive
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or your
business and you're feeling bold answer
these questions in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to just give a shot number two
how can you surround yourself with
greatness and number three what will you
do when you don't believe in yourself
positive service announcement to
everyone be careful who you help off
meaning the best friend could be right
beside you only the hate only the one to
be in your position only to want to envy
you or cause more confusion in your
lives to elevate themselves you could do
a thousand and one things to these
people you know but the minute you say
no everybody forgets bro
everybody has amnesia they act they act
accordingly but you can't let that you
know deter you from being a good person
and actually care about people you just
got to be cognizant of it I recognize
this the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you liked this video and you want to
learn more from what a Chris Brown's as
heroes Michael Jackson go check out the
video next mate I think you're gonna
enjoy continue to believe and I'll see
you there
it is my philosophy - if you want to
make the world a better place take a
look at yourself and then make a change